-Welcome, welcome, welcome,
welcome to
"The Tonight Show."
You made it.
You're watching.
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]
Well, guys, this is big news --
for the first time
in over a year,
New York City has resumed
24-hour subway service.
[ Cheering and applause ]
That's right, the subways are
once again running
24 hours a day,
minus the 23 hours
they're out of service,
[ Laughter ]
but, still.
That's right,
the subway's running 24 hours.
This is great news
for the city, but,
a tough break
for all the rat weddings
that are scheduled
between 2:00 and 4:00 am.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Unfortunate.
Do you guys remember
simpler times in New York City,
when the biggest health crisis
was a pole on the 7 train?
[ Laughter ]
Touch that thing.
I'd rather fall into someone
than touch that pole.
[ Laughter ]
That's right, there's the A,
there's the B, the C,
a bunch of other types
of hepatitis
you can get on the subway.
Just be careful
when you grab that pole.
[ Laughter ]
Speaking of New York,
the Brooklyn Nets are
in the NBA playoffs.
-Oh! Wow!
[ Cheering and applause ]
They're in the NBA playoffs
and Mayor Bill de Blasio
showed his team spirit
while announcing
that their arena will also be
a vaccination site.
Check out how he was dressed.
-The Nets are now going to be
joining the battle against COVID
with a mobile vaccination site
right outside Barclays Center.
[ Laughter ]
Right now, Jay-Z is like,
"Thank God I sold my piece
of the Nets."
[ Laughter and applause ]
He looks like a guy
who sits courtside
and can't get any high-fives
from the players.
You know that guy?
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, the classic basketball fan
outfit -- hat, jersey,
and a blue button-down
over the jersey.
I don't think I've ever
seen anyone wear that
[ Laughter ]
in my life, ever
You don't think there'd be
someone in the office
to go like, "Anh...
Why don't you put the jersey
over the shirt, maybe?
Ah, you know what?
Put the shirt over the jersey."
[ Laughter ]
-The first thing you do is,
"Are you alright?"
You know, "Are you okay?"
-That's the fashion version
of an air ball, you know?
[ Laughter ]
Rob Lowe looked more natural
at the NFC Championship
and he was just --
I guess he was rooting
for football, there.
[ Laughter ]
Speaking of vaccination sites,
later this week,
a strip club in Las Vegas
will be offering
the COVID vaccine.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Alright,
now, we're up to two poles
you shouldn't
put your hands on, okay?
[ Laughter ]
That's right, the strip club is
the only vaccination site
where you leave
and still need to get tested.
You know what I'm saying?
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
when you walk into the club,
there's a sign that says,
"Two-dose minimum,"
you know what I'm saying?
[ Laughter ]
The idea makes sense.
If we're being honest,
the vaccines
do kind of sound
like stripper names, like,
"Put your hands together
for Moderna!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Vuvuzela blasts ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
Well, guys, COVID restrictions
are being lifted
around the country,
which means people are finally
getting out for the first time
in over a year
and a lot of us have forgotten
what's normal behavior
and what's not.
For example,
it's normal for things
to get a little stressful
at the grocery store
when it's busy,
but it's not normal doing this.
-Police say a fight broke out
between two women
in the potato chip aisle.
Security footage caught
one woman
hitting the woman in the face
with a 10-pound log
of prepackaged meat.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Also, with the weather
warming up,
it's normal if you want to go
outside and hang out.
What's not normal
is doing it like this.
-One South Florida man tried
to tell police
he was just hanging out.
The only problem was he was
relaxing on a traffic light.
[ Laughter ]
Finally, it's totally normal
to start traveling again, okay?
What's not normal
is doing this.
-A Colorado man is facing
federal charges this morning,
accused of disrupting
an Alaska Airlines flight
by refusing to wear a mask
and then urinating in the cabin.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Oh, my God.
-He was pissed.
[ Laughter ]
-Some news out of Washington --
last night, President Biden
released his tax returns
and the White House put out
a statement that said...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Then just to rub it
in Trump's face even more,
they tweeted it, you know.
[ Laughter ]
But this is nice --
according to their tax return,
the Bidens gave over $30,000
to charity, yeah.
It was an offshoot
of Big Brothers Big Sisters,
called
Big Bidens Little Carters.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Some news from overseas --
I read that Kim Jong-un
has banned citizens
from having mullets
or wearing skinny jeans.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Right now, everyone's like,
"I can't believe
I'm saying this,
but I agree with Kim Jong-un."
[ Laughter and applause ]
I mean, come on,
compared to Kim Jong-un,
all pants are skinny pants.
Look at this.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Let me see that picture again.
-Come on.
-His waist and his leg hole
are both size 38.
[ Laughter ]
Listen to this --
according to a new report,
some U.S. airlines may start
weighing passengers
before they board their flight.
[ Booing ]
You know
Americans will be like --
[ Surfer voice ]
Wait, let me take off my mask
and see if that makes
a difference
because, you know,
I've been wearing it all day.
It's like four pounds
of mask weight, so.
[ Laughter ]
Now, when you get
to the airport,
you get searched and weighed.
We're basically
a urine sample away
from it being a full physical.
[ Laughter ]
It's not as bad as it sounds.
You just discreetly step
on a scale
and then, the pilot announces it
to everyone onboard.
"Okay, Jerry weighs 310 pounds."
[ Laughter ]
Some celebrity news --
over the weekend,
Ariana Grande surprised everyone
and got married
in a small ceremony. Hey!
[ Cheering and applause ]
We love you, Ariana!
We love Ariana.
[ Applause ]
It was the only wedding
where the priest said,
"We will now exchange
these seven rings."
[ Laughter ]
And, finally,
I was watching MSNBC yesterday
and something pretty unfortunate
happened to a cyclist
taking a selfie behind the
reporter. Watch this.
-And we know
that these changes --
-Oh!
-Oh, boy.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
Her friends were like,
"Well, on the bright side,
your selfie's trending."
Did you guys hear
about Andrew Giuliani?
He's Rudy Giuliani's son.
Well, he's running for governor
of New York in 2022.
-Ooh.
-And get this --
he's already testing out
some campaign slogans.
First up, there's --
-Oh, here we go!
[ Laughter ]
What's up?
-Let me guess -- you're going
to make fun of Andrew Giuliani
by saying a bunch
of fake slogans.
-Yeah, I mean,
that was the plan.
[ Laughter ]
And then,
each slogan is going
to pop up as a graphic,
so everybody can see it
and laugh about it.
[ Laughter ]
-Right. I often tell jokes
about the news.
-I know exactly
how this will go down.
The top of the screen
is going to have a picture
of Andrew Giuliani
and it'll say...
[ Laughter ]
And then, underneath that,
you'll list stuff, like...
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Or...
[ Laughter ]
-Yes. That's right.
-And then, and then...
[ Laughter ]
And then, you'll show
a photo of his dad
with his hair dye leaking
and then you'll do
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-a few more slogans, like...
[ Laughter ]
Or...
And then you'll end it, I guess,
with something on the nose,
like...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Is that how it's going to go?
-You nailed it.
-That's a fun bit, man.
You should do it.
[ Laughter ]
-Great. We'll do it tomorrow.